[Music]
for the loser now will be later to win
for the times they are changing stay
here
don't judge don't try don't stop don't
start just be here she knew the
equations that most people didn't know
they focused on the spirit of things and
saw perfection in the machines he made
I'm sure you've all heard that Steve
Jobs died of pancreatic cancer and
technically this is true he died of
respiratory arrest due to a pancreatic
neuroendocrine tumor but maybe he didn't
have to or at least he could have
delayed his death by ears if not decades
you see it while Steve Jobs did have
pancreatic cancer there was a silver
lining in that he had a special form of
pancreatic cancer caused by islet cells
regular pancreatic cancer only has a
five year survival rate of 1.8 percent
but isolate cell tumors have a fibrous
survival rate of up to 93 something
that's one of the odds even more in jobs
favor was that he found a cancer
extremely early jobs wasn't even at the
stage at which he was experiencing
symptoms due to the cancer in 2003 he
was actually suffering from kidney
stones and when doctors performed a CT
scan they just happened to notice a
shadow on his pancreas so if jobs took
quick action he could have very well
extended his lifespan by a substantial
amount but he chose not to in fact he
consistently delayed medical treatment
over and over again for months of the
rest of his life for example given Steve
Jobs wealth and Status he probably could
have scheduled a surgery within a week
of finding the tumor but instead it he
decided to wait nine months by which
point the cancer had already spread to
his liver another example of job
stubbornness was when he refused a liver
transplant from Tim Cook despite
desperately needing one job said that he
didn't want his body to be opened and
that he didn't want to be violated in
that way while that is understandable
this was literally a choice between life
and death also I don't think anyone
wants to be violated in that way people
go through these procedures because they
have to not because they want to but
instead jobs felt that the best course
of action was to stay on a strict vegan
diet and use Herbal Remedies and
acupuncture while these choices this may
offer benefits in day-to-day life
there's virtually no scientific evidence
that they help with cancer and given
that jobs was the founder and CEO of
what would eventually become the largest
company in the world you would think
that he was extremely rational and
objective with these choices but that
was far from being the case people that
knew him speculate that he felt that the
problem would just disappear if he
ignored it this line of reasoning had
worked for him in business in the past
after all his job was to literally
create unimaginable products and
convince the world to use them but this
approach didn't quite work within the
medical industry aside from jobs reality
Distortion classes something else that
was pushing jobs to make these choices
was his spiritual life and especially
his beliefs in Buddhism and the
afterlife jobs even said maybe it's
because I want to believe in an
afterlife that when you die it doesn't
just all disappear the wisdom you've
accumulated somehow it lives on so
here's the story of how jobs develop
these spiritual beliefs and how they
eventually played a role in his demise
taking a look back job spiritual beliefs
predate his cancer by decades in fact he
was a hippie for basically his entire
life which is not that surprising given
the time period in which he grew up if
you're not familiar with hippies these
were a group of people that rejected a
traditional middle-class life which they
felt was dominated by materialism and
repression instead it they embraced
openness peace and experimentation they
were known for vegetarian diets
ballistic medicine and of course
psychedelics jobs was especially
interested in the latter and regularly
experimented with them throughout his
late teenage years for him this wasn't
just a matter of getting high or trying
to live life more fully it was actually
a coping mechanism that he used to deal
with the pain that his birth parents
abandoned him according to jobs
psychedelics along with Primal screaming
opened up storage trauma in the medulla
and jobs took many of these habits and
beliefs with them to Apple One frowned
upon habit that he took with them was
his tendency to not take showers jobs
believed that his commitment to a vegan
diet meant that he had flushed out all
of the mucus from his body so
theoretically he believed that he
shouldn't have a body odor and that he
didn't need showers in reality this is
not even true vegan diets tend to skew
away from proteins which play a
significant role in the body's
detoxification process so jobs a vegan
diet likely meant that he should have
taken more showers not less and let's
just say his co-workers strongly agreed
another unique trait of jobs was his
tendency to walk around the Barefoot he
felt that walking around helped him
think and be more creative and that
there is some truth to this moving
around it does energize our brains and
it reduces stress making it easier to
focus on singular thoughts and ideas but
jobs didn't just walk around the
Barefoot he did some weird things
Barefoot jobs like to sink his feet into
cold water to de-stress and this seems
completely harmless at first and it
should be if done like a normal person
maybe you could fill a ball up with
water or maybe even buy a pedicure bowl
but instead job sunk his feet into
toilets at the office I suspect that
this only made his body odor worse it
wasn't just his body that he did these
weird experiments on either jobs also
practiced this hippie anti-establishment
mindset and other facets of his life as
well like his car Dobbs wasn't a fan of
having a license plate on his car for
some reason when questioned about it he
simply said that he didn't have a
license plate because he didn't have a
license plate the way that he made this
work was by getting new leases every six
months California law a lot of people
did not have a license plate for the
first six months after getting a new car
and the jobs exploited this loophole
until he died it wasn't till 2019 that
California finally patched this loophole
while all of these likely just seemed
like odd quirks jobs strongly believed
in each and every one of them and these
unorthodox choices carried over to his
medical choices as well
foreign
jobs hippie Behavior itself was extreme
then you haven't heard about his
spiritual life from his college days
jobs was especially interested in
Buddhism this interest was initially
sparked out of necessity as opposed to
curiosity you see it as a broke college
student free food was a gift and one of
the places that offered free food was
the Hare Krishna Temple near Reed
College every Sunday jobs walked seven
miles to the temple just to get free
food but very soon he walked away with
much more than just food jobs became
especially interested in Mahatma Gandhi
and a Hindu Sage named neem Corolla Baba
pretty soon jobs was talking to his
friends about this age and his teachings
and even though most of his friends were
hippies themselves they were pretty open
to the ideas of peace and Enlightenment
eventually they would get to a point
where they wanted to go meet the neem
cruelibaba in real life but they just
had one issue they were still broke but
as fate would have it an opportunity
would Arise at the time jobs was working
as a consultant at a game development
company called Atari one of their most
popular games was pong you've probably
played it pong gave Atari International
notoriety and a company from Germany
would buy a whole Warehouse full of
circuit boards from Atari unfortunately
though Atari didn't quite make a good
first impression given that half the
boards didn't end up working it out of
the box naturally the German company
wasn't very happy and that they wanted
someone to come out there and fix them
initially atari's founder Nolan Bushnell
sent over a tech guide to Germany but
this guy just made things worse so Nolan
turned to jobs he told the jobs that he
would book him a first class round-trip
ticket to Germany and a five-star hotel
if he could go fix this issue jobs
agreed to take the job but he had one
condition he wanted a one-way ticket to
Germany and wanted the rest of the
travel expenses in cash additionally he
negotiated that once the job was done he
was gone and that's exactly what
happened he finished the job in Germany
and went to India with a Dan Kottke
unfortunately though India didn't quite
live up to his Expectations first of all
the guy they were trying to meet name
Crowley Baba had already died a year
before this and that they simply hadn't
heard the news yet jobs also quote found
India far poorer than he imagined and
was struck by the incongruity between
the country's condition and its Heirs of
Holiness but by far the worst part of
the trip was the constant sickness the
duo picked up lice infections and the
worst of Allah uncontrollable diarrhea
by the end of the trip jobs had lost a
bunch of weight but what he didn't lose
was his belief while his belief in
Hinduism decreased his belief in
Buddhism became stronger than ever
thank you
when jobs returned to the United States
He implemented many Buddhist principles
into his day-to-day life one of his
strongest Buddhist beliefs was that
everything happens for a reason and that
nothing is random this was one of the
ways that he coped with being fired from
Apple in the 80s he eventually came to
accept that none of the successes that
followed this event like Pixar and the
iPhone would have taken place if he
hadn't been fired from Apple he also
adopted a much more pragmatic
perspective when it came to death
remembering that I'll be dead soon is
the most important Tola I've ever
encountered to help me make the big
choices in life because almost
everything of all external expectations
all pride of fear of embarrassment or
failure these things just fall away in
the face of death leaving only what is
truly important this was likely one of
the reasons that he refused to get
surgery from his perspective getting
surgery seemed unnatural and intrusive
and that this went against all of his
hippie and the Buddhist beliefs jobs
eventually make the leap though by the
time he died he would go from refusing
treatment to trying to get experimental
treatment in 2009 for example jobs would
travel to Switzerland to experiment with
their radioactive isotope the isotope
was supposed to attack the faulty
hormone producing cells in the body he
would also try to use his money to
accelerate the process of getting a
liver which many people felt was unfair
he didn't cut lines or do anything
illegal but what he did do was sign up
on deliver transplant lists around the
world this increased the chances that he
would get a matching donor somewhere
personally I don't think this is a
problem given that it's only natural
that you try to use all the resources
that you have to try to save your life
but some like to argue that this is not
something that the average person would
be able to do and so it's unethical let
me know which side you guys stand on it
down below but anyway the saddest part
of all of this is that jobs would
eventually regret his early choices he
admitted that he was wrong for rejecting
a professional help and this is just
made it worse by cancer experts
constantly affirming that he could still
be alive if he had just had surgery
earlier but in the end the thing to keep
in mind is that everyone dies at some
point but not everyone lives this
however was never the case with Steve
Jobs since the age of 17 he lived by the
quote if you live each day as if it was
your last someday you'll most certainly
be right and considering his impact on
the world there's no doubt that he lived
by the slogan till the very last day are
you a fan of Steve Jobs comment that
down below also drop a like if you hope
jobs is resting in peace and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community suggested video ideas and it
consider subscribing see more questions
and logically answered but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one